[Music]  tell me about your look what secrets are  in this dress miss Nicki Minaj I can't  tell you the secrets because I have to  kill you but it's made by probable groom  and I'm really excited I feel very  barbie-ish you're sort of the queen of  camp you've pulled out so many campy  looks throughout your career do you have  a favorite music video kampl up oh  that's a great question  I have no clue because up until today I  had no idea what camp was so I don't  even know if this is camp to be honest  you've been doing it though your whole  career you're extra you're loud you're  unapologetic that is camp well thank you  are you gonna be able to party in these  boots shoes I feel like they need to  come off as soon as you get in as soon  as I get in these shoes I probably come  off yeah honestly  you